today's episode is brought to you by
shadow of the Tomb Raider available
September 14th pre-order now for two-day
early access well welcome to the honest
trailer commentary for predator
yeah it's predator today needs if we can
commentate on it I couldn't be more
happy to talk about this movie because
it's freakin perfect if you stick around
you'll see some a few deleted jokes
not much there's pretty much everything
we had to say about it made it in and
we're going to talk about that right now
with Joestar and with Dan Worrell yeah
and with me Spencer Shay Gilbert
predators good movie guys alright I
wouldn't call it perfect there are
things you could change but it is such a
because they're tweaks yeah
trims their nips their tucks yeah
they're like if I had to like if I was
given the responsibility to do something
or like I lose my home yeah there's
tweaks but yeah this is easier than die
hard mmm because you have the sweatiness
you have the Arnold factor you have the
machismo that just crawls out of the
screening room there was a lot more
footholds on this movie than there were
on die hard so I will say well I love
both of these movies very much this was
slightly easier than a movie like die
hard which is amazing and also like
where do you would you grab on to it
that movie had them good yeah there's
these things you can poke at with a
stick in this movie there are things
wrong with the movie but there's always
like fun stuff like you say sweatiness
like we yeah and in the other direction
not so much cons but pros is we talked
about but then cut how deep this movie
is how there's layers it seems so simple
and it is so simple and my favorite
movies are like this where like it is
about soldiers go to jungle they it gets
fubar and they get hunted by a by a
predator but it's actually could it be
about Vietnam could it be about
masculinity itself there's many readings
to predator mmm many readings I think it
lends itself to repeat viewings and to
- maybe a more of a metaphorical view
than just what's happening on the carry
I think I think you give this thing
similarites I mean it's definitely got
to be a nom definitely have got to have
some nom connotations yeah but guys who
are definitely in not walking around in
the jungle yeah it's more complicated
than you think there's Soviets doing
stuff and they they get it first they
think it's gonna be a cakewalk and then
they get kind of stymied there and then
they just have to leave with honor
then they desperately just want to get
to the choppa yeah I'm a real dummy
because I just watch this to watch
arnold schwarzenegger shoot the jungle
that's I guess I probably should have
seen the commentary going on in that
scene but I just like the guns shoots
the jungle I call it Arnold shoots the
jungle and ones like we have one main
note yeah props to McTiernan though for
probably the best he did do one film
before this but like the best one-two
punch hard yeah with each other
that's the hot start there's a hot start
there's a hot hand start yeah and then
yes fine then whoa rollerball whoa yeah
yeah I don't know prison he went to do
went to prison for a bit
money stuff I think I think I don't know
I'd have to go back I can't remember why
but yeah so he learned something he his
perception on filmmaking changed in
those walls yeah
changed seriously there was a point that
we didn't get to make in this trailer
because this is impossible plus for
copyright reasons but it's it's
something I didn't notice till like the
last few times that I watched the movie
but it's alan silvestri is an incredible
composer yep amazing however if you
listen to his score for this movie and
his score for back to the future
they are strikingly similar they both
have that did it do and then did you
have the snare
you have the horns if I'm not blaming
him he's done so many amazing scores
before and after I think he was I think
he was a little overworked it was the
mid 80s who knows what else was going on
everywhere in Hollywood but if you
listen to his score for bed to the
future and his score for predator they
are strikingly similar I'm a dummy in
the sense that I had never heard it
before until you pointed it out and then
I was like how oh yeah because they if
you put them in their own context like
I'd never you could play without telling
me like hey have you ever notice the
themes you could play me like a chunk of
back to the future and then predator and
I would have just not because so
something about it shredded or maybe
they were rushed or something but they
used like the same bongo drum sample
like maybe 17 times in the first 20
minutes of like hey it works it works
and it's not even that the score is like
it's like the same melody or the same
notes but it's as if you were making as
Carl Weathers is a fan of ass - yeah and
you just have the same and you just have
the same base our branch that you're
stirring the pot with that's the stew of
the Back to the Future score and the
stew of the predator score yes and the
exact same ingredient a lot of stews
start with a strong tomato base but
they're still they're very apparent on
first taste let's watch a let's trailer
for pressure
[Music]
from the Michael Bay of the 80s but
better comes a bill that combines the
best action the best forces the jump and
the best handshake in all of human
history you son of a [ __ ] that sound
music that sound that their hands make
thanks for positive G I like the nose
it's like a clap of thunder I mean good
lord I've read some of the behind the
scenes or like a oral history of this
it's like of course Arnold brought the
entire gym to the jungle with him and
all these guys would just pump oh yeah
morning noon and night before they get
on camera so that have max sweat Oh even
if you had never exercised before in
your life if you end up on a set like
this yeah you're gonna you're gonna
start you're not gonna be the one guy in
the ensemble it's like that moment Peak
80s is that moment when the 80s peaked
when when Carl Weathers and arms forcing
her clasped hands like that was that men
are muscles yeah yeah I think it might
have been I was gonna say over-the-top
but that probably came JT would years
over the top 87 so that was on the
downhill I would say that when the wave
had just started to crest and gotten too
ridiculous this is the peak this is
where it all happened this is the where
the eighties and her summited and
respect to over-the-top but I feel like
over-the-top is someone saw this and was
like that'd be a good move you know my
favorite part of the predator was just
that I'm gonna look up while we're doing
this yeah keep making it I what do you
say JT 87 they were both 87 yeah Wow
all right it's just in the air yeah it's
like I'm getting a deep impact too
sweaty
armed clenching muscle man movies in the
same year that's pretty incredible
yeah alright let's keep going
so does anyone else grew a moustache
every time they watch that
redditor deep in the heart of the
Central American jungle where no one can
hear you sweat profusely sweat
everything oh yeah
something is hunting men for sport and
that something would have been an
awesome mystery if they didn't show a
spaceship in the first scene trees it's
an alien besides them yep
alien saw the ship or something out
there waiting for us okay fine I'll do
it you two comments do movie starts at 1
minute 29 seconds this is a discussion
we had if you skipped the first 90
seconds of the movie you don't know what
something you don't know what's out
there
yeah also something I never thought
about until yeah this is your pool yeah
it's all the same who knows though I
wasn't gonna say who knows if the if the
movie would have been was I say well I
think you have to establish the I guess
they felt like you have to establish the
premise of the film right that front
does the movie does the movie suffer if
you're given no explanation of the
predator or is it fine yeah like if it's
just there's this thing out there I know
I remember I was gonna say this is just
like Terminator 2 in the trailer for
Terminator 2 where that movie is just it
was so much better if you haven't seen
that Arnold is good about if this had
he's a good guy yeah you can't tell and
if they hadn't revealed it in the
trailer and in this movie I think it's
so much better if you don't know what
the predator is yeah until you know
minute 45 mmm-hmm every beat of t2 also
builds that suspense so well and you
know that they Cameron had to be pissed
yeah when you saw that trailer yeah cuz
until he says good down you don't know
yeah you think it's good just be hunting
him yeah yeah who knew who knows people
I guess people like movie spoiled in the
trailers that's what they say that's
what the atom believed by the way over
the top by the way came out 4 months
before predator it was it was build-up
build-up to the predator they probably
flew a chopper to Arnold and Carl
Weathers like we got up do a pickup
you're Arnold's an early screening of it
was like I can't have Stallone how does
he do it how do I do it every time was
that the first subtweet yes I do
commando with pumps of Rambo
no no get Carroll in the food well Karl
this is next time like yeah yeah I'm
here
uh-huh whatever it is he just said sure
there's Jim - right next to you yeah
wait did rocky for come out the same
year whoa no 88 all right I'm gonna this
is the research research commentary
because that would be incredible that
would be like the the America's muscular
peak was in 788 oh yeah 85 tell me what
you think though because after you had
mentioned that I was like holy [ __ ] and
I really thought about losing the
spaceship scene like do you have to have
a it's an alien reveal later or is it
fine yeah I think it's obviously like
well that's not a draft like yeah that
something was up I guess you could
feasibly be like that's a really weird
guy yeah yeah what's up with that guy
yeah yeah we could have to cut the space
at the end I get it but also at the same
time it would have enhanced they are
saving themselves problems for later by
sort of lessening yeah yeah impact
they've gone with the original predator
design you would have known it innately
yes voice of I Bryan Cranston probably
will get to look at people let's keep
going kittens join an elite squad of
assassins via rescue team not assassins
don't forget your minigun they're really
trained around the macho Native American
Blaine the jacked-up macho redneck back
in Dillon the checked up macho black
eyes honcho of the jacked-up macho
Latino Hawkins the screenwriter they
wanted on the pawn shop well first of
all that's chain back um but poncho I
was reading he had worked out just as
much as the other guys but he got
decimated by like mosquitoes and ants
and Stephanie's discovered it bites so
like you had to put a shirt check out my
six-pack oh I'm gonna
in a movie with Arnold and Carl Weathers
[Laughter]
one joke that didn't make the cut that
we could not crack was the modern-day
equivalent for like what would it what
would because it's so weird that
somebody in the original predator movie
would go on to direct another predator
movie so it wasn't horrible and it
wasn't like we were trying to crack like
what movie how would that would be the
analogous thing now like what would be
the pole from a movie who would later go
on to direct that franchise because
that's such a weird thing to have a guy
that's like oh well I think like oh she
ain't black wrote predator like no yeah
he just it's like it was there right no
they had him there because they wanted
like a screenwriter on set Yeah right
funny jokes or whatever and apparently
the only thing he got in the whole movie
was the P words the second P word joke
the callback to the first one what if I
don't know like Vin Diesel in ten years
directing the reboot of guardians of the
galaxy yeah well I would say it's more
likely Fast and Furious to like no one
wants to deal with that headache see
like Donald Glover doing like a Lando
movie yeah I can see that or would
direct their own thing you write in the
comments below
whoo yeah who would direct an
installment of a franchise that they've
just been an actor in you know that's a
funny patter in it do our job I need
like I would love to see if you got
complete creative control and like and
you somehow forced the rock to be in it
yeah Toretto you're just a bigger
stronger man than me and a better actor
that's right and him saying cut and
print is in the movie he's like what can
I do to just make the rock look like
less of a man is like Toretto I'm scared
hold me just hold me forgive me for
voting for Trump why is that none of
this has anything to do with the script
maybe you just don't understand my
writing
I've been watching you okay hey guy I
guess
triple x 5 or whatever the latest one
was is is close to that pretty he's
gonna direct either a xxx you're fast
enough here yeah it's gonna happen I
also don't know my VIN sounds like Snake
Plissken yours your VIN sound good -
sounds like punch-drunk rocky baby
commercial claymation right a fighters
and their leader Dutch ejecta betta
cigar-chomping Kevin McAllister kudos to
our editors for split screen is
perfectly
[Music]
keep the change you filthy animal yeah
thrill as they're up against the
ultimate enemy jean-claude van damme in
a stupid lobster costume applause that
really happened guy was the original
predator yeah they work I don't know
yeah I mean they were gonna edit it out
like like you know doing an invisible
thing on this but that's that's the
design more or less and also in that
oral history which I recommend everyone
read they were like seven competing
versions for wide shot content and left
the movie every it's like Rashomon like
everyone has a different point of view
it's like he got fired because he was
complaining and demanded he do karate or
he was just too short to do it or they
were just like well the costume stupid
so let's get rid of the guy too
like it's amazing how every single
person has like their recollection of
white Jean Claude Van Damme his minute
yeah yeah someone should go straight to
the source
well actually that probably the least
reliable yeah absolutely
no John Claude Van Damme would just be
like well Arnold was very upset that I
beat him to within within an inch of his
life with words and fists and asked that
I be removed and 15 security men came to
remove me and I did the splits right
JCVD is he is he dutch is he actually
Dutch he's from Brussels is that does
that count I don't I know nothing about
Europe I was told there would be no
geography the joke is that he would be
mad that somebody else was called betch
but I'm not sure if that worked you know
I don't think it's probably a Belgian oh
yeah he's Belgian right remember well
Brussels sounds like it's something in
Belgium
now where's Dutch good syrup for the
Netherlands hey commenters who are the
Dutch who are the Dutch to Syria and now
I said that to Syria no no Hank hey Siri
where is jean-claude van damme from
Brussels I know that yep he's from
Brussels okay now who are the Dutch we
know Brussels
hey Siri where is the Dutch oh no no
we're Brussels I need to know what
qualifies is Dutch I think you have any
for Amsterdam for the Netherlands
nothing specific not gonna know how to
answer what qualifies I'd like to
apologize to our international audience
this is the American school system it's
everything it's been built up to be you
just have to be blonde right yeah I
think that's it let's go with that
yeah long time yeah it's ago Dutch is
relating to the Netherlands it's people
or their language now is Brussels the
Netherlands no no okay
we knew that too we did okay they share
a common Brussels is in Belgium okay
Rembrandt was Dutch all right let's keep
going JT I'll do this along laughter yep
that really happened but once he got
fired they went up we're doing the
bloodsport on Sunday the predator a
perfect mix of awesome creature design
as in a mesh bodysuit and Vincent Price
laughs who uses advanced technology to
hunt the equivalent of fish in a barrel
yeah I guess he's less cool when you
realize he's like those yuppies who
shoot two rats with a sniper rifle
so before you see the predator yep III
miss if the predator has never been
improved on and it's sequels and could
be released in theaters today because
it's aged so well mostly well yeah it
doesn't have to the horror movie this
good with sewing that Connor y-yeah such
an iconic booby monster you'll barely
even notice that half the film is just
quietly looking at trees
don't the barrels and jaws yeah you have
to stand in use it for junctures it's an
alien story never hold a major governor
of California the future governor of
Minnesota a future candidate for
governor of Kentucky okay this is
getting weird
maybe you've got a stupe going to
moisturize see to the direction of Iron
Man 3 and I gotta get to the job my
skull my back my trophy in my pack and
the end credits that make the movie look
like a 90s and here's a good thing these
are not shots from the movie now these
were shattered
specifically they just born one day like
yeah let's pretend predator yeah yeah my
main another expendable
you changed Arnold you changed to fight
each other finally finally those end
credits they really it's not just that
they haven't because a lot of like like
airplane had like lucky in credits but
that's airplane like yeah you've seen
these men mercilessly gutted and skinned
go heads blown off most confident cocky
men to just empty shells themselves
begging for death it's an odd choice
it's like remember I got the headed it's
really hereditary did not end with Toni
Collette like I just love to that um
it's not just that they're cheesy but
each of them were like what's the most
testosterone manliest thing I can do to
just drop the panties right now throw me
that ak-47 so that good job the only one
who doesn't record their own is Arnold
Arnold is just a clip from the RL is a
clip from the film I don't have time for
that [ __ ] yeah Arnold is literally just
a clip from the movies like all right
Arnold time of your coaches I'm not
doing god I got the good the arm shot
let me loan have you guys ever listened
to pumping up with Arnold the actual
album his actual workout album workout
album like an audio workout yak a record
oh my god is it I know I know it's
amazing
it's uh it's him like trying to keep
rhythm with uh with just music it's like
just like beats and he's like and flex
just is it like his DVD commentaries or
he's just describing what oh my god
no it's it's him trying to rhythmically
tell you how to workout and it's kind of
great okay like flicks flicks and shred
Joe I need to take a slight issue with
your Arnold impression there but maybe I
haven't listened to it yeah I'm not a
depressions guy that's all Dan will go
listen to it after this after I listen
to Total Recall yeah considered a
divorce I know I know now he's outside
this head is exploding like yes I know
that we know this is not the descriptive
audio yes Thank You Arnold that's very
the kind of the Conan ones like that -
just like this is the pasta was
shirtless then we ran around and I had
the soul that I swang it yeah woman was
very beautiful I know yes I know Arnold
thank you or we can see the film in
addition to you speaking thank you he
doesn't know that he doesn't know we got
some cut Joe doing
hey I'm starring the least story past
action hero cue an odd turn into the
last action hero.the body's very
underrated
Oh real Adonis Danny Tata vagina
80 of these heat vision and jacked
that's a space Dothraki
fatality treadline the monster to catch
a predator and rumble in the jungle
literally anywhere and that's it that's
it yeah very economical much like the
predator itself you know we're very lean
we used every part of the animal yeah
we ripped the skull out of our jokes and
yeah I don't have no end of that
metaphor polish that spine yeah
so yeah predator near-perfect movie not
perfect but that's how we do in
Australia for one of those you have fun
with it it's a printers one of those
movies that actually has a honest
trailer style trailer for it I urge
everyone to look those up if you're
young to see what we're actually people
don't know we're actually parroting
anymore because they don't make those
trailers they do not make them like that
anymore yeah so yeah predator is one of
those diehard not so much die hard but
die hard 2 also has was like it's
Christmas Eve John McClane is flying
home to his family reviews that kind of
used to be well you know they were
definitely biased yes diehard Tuesday's
ones it's like last time he blew you out
of the wall like this time he'll blow
you out of the ceiling like it's such
like that is anything that we were
parroting it's that kind of trailer yeah
so check those out they stopped making
those bull keep making these honest
trailer commentaries see you next week
for oh we hadn't released that someone
also call an action movie yeah that is a
sequel as that also might have partially
taken place in to jungle good clues good
see you then I like oh yeah
you
[Music]